Good morning, everybody.
Last week we covered the
cultural politics of the
early 1970s and also the
rise of different types of
politics in the, in
the, sort of the,
this--think of a word
that actually--in a bowl,
a cauldron of
politics in the early 1970s,
whether it's
grassroots affairs,
high politics with the
Congressional Black Caucus,
and running
throughout all of,
all of that, the
complications imposed by,
by a commitment to
formal modes of political
engagement, while you
have someone like Shirley
Chisholm coming along.
So you see the way in which
gender is this fault line
when it comes to race
politics in the nation in
the early 1970s.
And it's been a fault
line for the longest time,
of course.
What I want to do today is
cover chronologically a lot
of the same time
period, but through,
through a biography.
One person I've not really
mentioned much at all in the
course in the
last few weeks,
but who's becoming
incredibly important as we
go through the 1970s
and into the 1980s,
is Jesse Jackson.
So I want to focus on this
sort of political biography
of this person as a way
to help us understand,
maybe even summarize really,
the shifting cultural
politics of the 1960s, of
the rise of a different
array of
politics in the 1970s,
and then heading us into
really what is this week is
mainly about, is high,
high, high politics as far,
in, in, in the--as the way
they are expressed through
presidential politics.
So basically, at
any given moment,
you could go
through high, low,
medium levels of politics.
This week, we'll be moving
from the grassroots through
Jesse Jackson, up through
the highest echelons of
power in the United States.
Now last Monday, I concluded
the lecture playing an
excerpt from Stevie
Wonder--Stevie Wonder's song
"Big Brother" from 1972.
One of the lines--I
don't expect you to remember
it--he's talking
about "My name is Nobody,
and saying you,
the person listening,
The Man, "your
name is Big Brother."
And I mentioned last
Monday how that's actually a
harkening to Jesse
Jackson's own politics,
and you'll see this coming
out in the middle of today's
lecture.
So this is just to point out
these are overlapping time
periods.
So Jesse Jackson.
The most basic biography,
starting with him as a
college student.
He graduates from North
Carolina Agricultural and
Technical
University down in,
in Greensboro,
North Carolina.
Same school where,
before he matriculated,
four young men marched into
Woolworth's and started the
famous bus
boycott--excuse me,
the sit-in movement.
So Jackson, although not
politically engaged when he
gets to campus, knows that
he's arrived at a place that
is suffused with now a young
but very vibrant history of
political engagement in the
student politics of the era.
He goes through
A&T, graduates,
and while he's in college,
finally decides to answer a
call he'd been struggling
with for a long time,
and that's a call to faith.
So he goes to Chicago
Theological Seminary.
He's in seminary
when the SNCC marchers,
led by John Lewis, get
attacked by the police and
it turns into Bloody Sunday.
He leaves
Chicago--this is '65,
of course--he leaves Chicago
and heads down to Selma.
You know, he is like
thousands of other African
American, white,
brown, whatever,
individuals who come to
Selma to try to be part of
the solution.
He's in Alabama, and he
joins other young civil
rights workers
on the ground,
you know, a number of whom
have gone on to great fame
and then also infamy.
People like Marion
Barry, the former mayor of
Washington,
D.C., for example,
was a fantastically
important activist,
civil--student, civil rights
activist during this era.
Jackson, in the midst of
these other clearly talented
people, he still stands out.
More than anything else, he
stands out because of his
ability to speak.
He is, you know, whatever
you might think of his
politics, he is
clearly one of the great,
one of the great
speakers in our,
in our moment, in our lives.
And essentially,
he talks his way,
though sheer force
of will and charisma,
he talks his way into the
inner-circle of leaders.
He's no longer just a
foot soldier down there,
trying to complete
this march from Selma to
Montgomery.
He sees himself really
having an important role to
play in the inner-circle.
And in short notice,
he's actually now in King's
inner-circle, so he's right
around the leader of this
moment.
Very early on, there begins
to be whispers about Jesse
Jackson: a little bit
too good to believe;
an incredible
opportunist; you know,
unbridled ambition.
And these are all, you know,
concerns that have followed
Jackson throughout his
entire political career,
of course, but they're
starting at that very
moment.
The SCLC--[Student sneezes]
bless you--The SCLC,
sensing that they've got
somebody special in their
midst who can really
make a difference,
is engaged in something,
sends him back to Chicago.
And the
leadership of the SCLC,
King included--[Student
sneezes] bless you.
Oh I thought I heard
another sneeze coming,
it is allergy season, after
all--they see Jackson as a
person who can sort of
establish a beachhead for
SCLC, dealing with
economic issues.
Now remember, S--SCLC
heads to Chicago in '66,
so Jackson is sent there to
sort of pave the ground and
get things set up.
What he does when he gets
there is sets up a group
called
Operation Breadbasket,
and it is a, a group
underneath SCLC's umbrella.
Operation Breadbasket is
solely based in Chicago and
with Jackson's great
charisma and power,
he starts having
great success,
and starts developing real,
real powerful leadership
networks,
kinships in Chicago.
Now what was Operation
Breadbasket all about?
It was about trying
to diversify business
opportunities and service
in the black community in
Chicago.
This is a highly
segregated city,
very large and densely
packed neighborhood in the
South Side of Chicago.
It's much more
than a neighborhood.
And Jackson uses
a strategy he's,
he's maintained for decades,
that's the economic boycott.
So Operation Breadbasket is
organized around the idea,
we will boycott, we'll
gather together black
consumer purchasing power,
and we will boycott Chicago
companies that don't conduct
better business practices
in, in--business
practices--practices in
black communities.
Because Jackson has been so
successful at getting people
together, I mean, Operation
Breadbasket is doing all the
classic things that, that
civil rights groups are
doing, have done, throughout
the breadth of this course.
I mean they're
also, you know,
putting food on
people's tables,
they're providing job banks,
they're basic--doing basic
education.
The companies quickly
concede because Operation
Breadbasket is,
is, it's working,
and so you see companies
start hiring black managers.
This is important.
I mean this is different
than the boycotts in the
past, like A.
Philip Randolph
was threatening,
where he's trying to get as
many black workers on the
factory floor, thinking back
to the defense industry jobs
in World War II.
Jackson is going at
the management level.
He's goes, "We can hire all
the black factory workers we
want, but there will
be a glass ceiling.
You won't break
into management.
You won't run the
business or franchise."
That's what Jackson's
target is--targets.
Companies recognize what's
going on and realize they'd
better get on board, so they
start hiring black managers.
Jackson then, with
the support of SCLC,
takes Operation
Breadbasket national.
It's going to be part of a
national economic engagement
with race politics.
Clearly,
Jackson's star is rising.
It's up in Chicago in
late '65 and by early '68,
Operation Breadbasket, that
he started for the SCLC,
is going national.
Then Martin Luther
King is assassinated.
The great prince
has been slain.
Now, in the moment
of an assassination,
people do all kinds of
things that are--you know,
we can overanalyze til we're
blue in the face--they do
things they don't really,
can't really quite explain.
But Jackson, Jackson
was kind of curious.
He's there when
King is assassinated.
I can't imagine
that kind of horror.
And for days afterward,
cameras would be following
Jackson and other
civil rights leaders,
just trying to, you
know, get a pulse on what's
happening, not just in
Memphis but around the
nation as cities burn.
And Jackson's wearing the
same clothes that he was
wearing when King
was assassinated.
He's dazed;
everybody's dazed,
there's no doubt about that.
But Jackson's clothes were
particularly noteworthy,
because they're
blood-stained.
They had King's
blood on his chest.
Now Jackson was right there,
there's blood going to be
everywhere.
Certainly you can excuse him
for not changing clothes for
a few days.
And then this is where
things get interesting,
is that people
start grousing.
Jackson said he's
going, you know,
he's going down to King's
body to try to stop the
bleeding.
He had blood on
his shirt--hands,
and just wiped it on his
shirt without thinking about
it.
It's a natural
kind of reaction.
Others start saying Jackson
deliberately put his hands
in King's blood and
deliberately wiped it on his
shirt.
Now I have no
idea what is true,
but the fact is, this is the
level of the conversation
within sort of closer
circles around King,
trying to understand, what
the heck is Jackson doing?
So you see Jackson with
the bloody shirt then,
being caught in this
interpretative moment.
Is he a symbol--is his
bloody shirt a symbol of the
nation's guilt, or was the
blood on Jackson's shirt a
symbol of his own anointment
of his leadership status
within black America?
Now helping understand some
of that really aggressive
critique of
Jackson, people thought,
you know, what, you know,
"What's he actually doing
here?"
It's important to understand
that when SCLC sent Jackson
up to be an
economic--set the,
the groundwork in Chicago,
a number of them were just
trying to get him
out of the South.
The man
wouldn't stop talking,
apparently, and King,
some--according to some
reports, like, "Just
get this kid out of here.
Send him to Chicago."
You know, "Have
him do something."
No one expected
him to succeed,
but he does succeed.
And his success
burnishes his ego,
which is
certainly substantial.
And of--without
great surprise,
his great success
also causes friction.
Nothing breeds
contempt like success,
after all.
So as Operation Breadbasket
continues to grow,
as Jackson seems
to declare himself,
if not the, then one of the
most important leaders in
black America after
King's assassination.
And there's certainly enough
confusion where that kind of
claim would make sense.
It becomes clear that SCLC
and Operation Breadbasket
are not going to succeed;
they're not going to survive
together.
Too many bulls in
the china shop.
So Jackson takes, or splits,
from SCLC in 1971 and forms
another
operation, Operation PUSH.
Now you may
remember, thinking back to,
I don't know, a month and
a half ago in the course,
a month ago in the course,
that after the success of
the Montgomery bus
boycott, King was thinking,
you know, what, what's the
next thing for him to do,
and Bayard Rustin says,
"You've got to have an
organization to
capitalize on this energy,
and Bayard Rustin wanted it
to be called the Southern
Leadership Conference, and
King changed the name to the
Southern Christian
Leadership Conference.
Well Jackson splits and
forms Operation PUSH,
People United to
Save Humanity.
It's what the
original title is.
People United to
Save Humanity,
and it's a perfect example
of Jackson's sense of
himself, that he can lead an
organization that will save
humanity, but he
had advisers as well,
say, you know,
"Jesse, that's a bit,
that's a bit much.
Heck, you're not even
thirty years old yet."
So the name of the operation
was changed before it went
public to Operation
PUSH, People United to Serve
Humanity, much more in the
spirit with the Christian
ethos that
Jackson stood for.
So Operation PUSH
is Chicago-based.
This is Jackson's bedrock,
his organizing center.
Its goal is very much
like Operation Breadbasket,
which is black empowerment.
And through Operation PUSH,
Jackson essentially becomes
the black ambassador to
white corporate America.
This is going
through the 1970s.
You know, think
of this moment,
we're, we're past the
Black Political Assembly.
We, you now had the
Congressional Black Caucus
formed.
You have real power, people
in positions of political
power in Congress.
You have the
angry activists,
of course, certainly, and
you have Jesse Jackson,
who's somewhere in between.
He can speak and rally a
black mass like nobody else
can, truly.
But he also knew
how to massage,
quote, "the system," and
talk to white business
managers and corporations,
first in Chicago and then
ultimately nationally.
He was very successful.
So he goes to huge
corporations now,
Coca-Cola,
Anheuser, excuse me,
Anheuser-Busch,
Kentucky Fried Chicken,
Burger King.
He's going to
these businesses,
knowing that there was a
disproportionate amount of
black purchasing
power related to these
corporations and
their products.
And he threatens a national
boycott of all of these
brands, unless blacks begin
to give--begin to receive
leadership roles in
these organizations.
This is now--we're, we've
now traversed the 1970s.
Now we're in 1981.
Corporations say, you know,
"We know who Jesse Jackson
is, but please, we are
not worried about this."
You know, "This is a
little bit embarrassing,
and it's true, we don't have
any blacks in management
positions in the comp--in
these huge companies,
essentially none, but we're
not going to worry about
it."
The boycotts are called.
And I remember the
Coca-Cola boycott,
mainly because I liked
Coca-Cola when I able to get
it--when I was able to get
it and because--and this is
actually more to the
point--Coca-Cola owns Minute
Maid orange juice.
I loved Minute
Maid orange juice,
and all of a sudden, it
was gone in my house.
Now I did not grow up in a
family of black militants.
I grew up in a family, my,
my father can't stand Jesse
Jackson, almost personally.
I really don't
know the, the,
the, the source of the bile,
but he just can't stand him.
But the boycott made
sense to my parents.
So replacing my beloved
Minute Maid orange juice was
this--I think it's still
made--this really bitter,
nasty Donald
Duck orange juice.
It was just horrible.
So I felt rather aggrieved
by the boycott myself.
But the boycott was
incredibly successful,
actually, and especially
with Coke and all of its
products.
Coke starts
losing money rapidly,
and Coke says,
"Well, we've got to,
we've got to fix this," and
they start targeting black
business leaders in
various communities to start
buying--allowing
them to buy franchises,
you know, the local
bottling franchise,
for instance.
And then a funny
thing happens.
Once Coke
changes its agenda,
its, its tactic
regarding this boycott,
and starts bringing in black
managers and franchisees,
they start making
money hand over fist.
They're embraced by the
black community even more so
than before, and
they start realizing,
"Hey, you know,
there's something to this."
And so Coke becomes a
model, to a certain extent,
which is very important,
to a certain extent,
of developing a
black consumer base.
In fact you have,
during this moment,
in the wake of
blaxploitation films,
who are realizing, "My god,
there's a lot of money to be
made in black America."
You have corporations sort
of waking up and realizing,
"There is a huge market we
have not bothered pursuing."
You know, whether they're
high-minded about civil
rights or
citizenship rights,
it doesn't matter.
This is about the
almighty dollar,
so corporations start
aggressively courting black
America and if, in
the case of Coca-Cola,
that meant hiring
black managers,
we're going to do it.
Now, the caveat to all
of this is that the glass
ceiling still remains there.
It's just a
little higher up.
And this would become a
case of great bitterness,
this phenomenon, as we go
through the 1980s into the
1990s, as this first
generation of black
managers, and women
managers as well,
start trying to move
further up in the hierarchy,
and they're stopped.
You actually have lawsuits
following in Coca-Cola.
Texaco was quite
famous in the,
in the
mid-to-late-1990s as well,
for a very powerful,
powerfully coherent glass
ceiling.
But in the early eighties,
some things changed,
and Jesse Jackson is the
person who led that change.
Now the success of the
boycott with Coca-Cola and
other corporations inspires
Jackson to do something
more.
He's going to run for
presidential office.
He runs in 1984, and it's
largely a symbolic campaign,
that is practically scuttled
from the start by Jackson's
loose sort of "politics
makes strange bedfellows"
affiliation with Louis
Farrakhan from the Nation of
Islam.
And, also, for an
unfortunate remark that
Jackson made
himself, referring to,
sort of one of
these passing comments,
probably made because
he was quite tired.
He referred to New
York City as "Hymietown."
That would be akin to
calling Washington,
D.C., "Niggerville"
in people's minds.
The mayor of New
York City, Ed Koch,
is infuriated
by the comment,
for good reason, no doubt.
And although Jackson
apologize--apologizes right
away, the mayor
wouldn't let up.
He just keeps hammering
away: this is who Jackson,
Jesse Jackson, really is.
Now we really know what's
up with this particular
individual.
And to make it worse, he's
associated with Farrakhan,
sympathetic to
the Palestinians.
You know, the whole thing's
wrapped up in this one
moment.
Again, Jackson apologized
for the remark as quickly as
he could, and
said, famously,
"God isn't
finished with me yet.
I'm far from perfect."
But the slur wiped
out his campaign.
In '88, he
decides to run again.
This time he--it is
not a symbolic campaign,
not by a long shot.
He's distanced
himself from Farrakhan.
He's much more politically
polished as far as,
sort of, national
presidential politics are
concerned.
And in fact, in '88, he
terrifies the Democratic
leadership when he
starts beating their people,
their likely candidates.
Now I know it sounds like
no big deal in the age of
Obama, in his
fantastic run in 2008,
but we have to
forget that for a moment,
go back twenty years.
And after Jackson wins
the Michigan primary,
he's actually the
frontrunner of the
Democratic campaign.
It's early on,
but people thought,
"The--Wait,
hold, stop a second!
I mean, it was cute
when he boycotted Coke,
you know, and his various
antics over time are,
you know,
inspirational, certainly,
but this is serious now.
He's a Democratic
front--frontrunner for a
series of primaries."
Now what's the change
between '84 and '88?
The big change is that,
aside from being more
polished, is that Jackson
really masters something
that Carl Stokes had done
twenty years earlier in
Cleveland, and he builds a
coalition that hadn't been
seen at the presidential
level be--had never been
seen at the
presidential level before,
through the
Rainbow Coalition,
this organization
that he also heads up.
He reaches out through the
Rainbow Coalition to people
of all kinds of
aggrieved backgrounds.
You know, blacks, of
course, are going to be his
strongest base, people
working in labor unions,
people trying to
organize into labor unions,
the agricultural workers,
reaching out to women,
to the poor.
And then during this moment
of great dawning awareness
of the AIDS crisis,
HIV and AIDS crisis,
he's reaching out to people
suffering from HIV and
reaches out to the
homosexual community,
something that was
quite shocking for Jackson.
He reaches out
to the disabled.
And he pulls them all
together in this great
quilt, is the
metaphor he uses a lot,
and says that he
speaks for everybody.
Now Jackson does not
win the nomination,
Dukakis does.
But Jackson, of
course, earns a spot on the
convention floor, and
his speech--and in,
in prime time, which is
one of the major things you
want.
And his speech on the
convention floor is
considered one of the
classics of the genre.
He reaches out during the
course of his speech to the
coalition I just
talked to you about.
Talks about this great quilt
to be made of everyone's
separate patches.
He criticizes Ronald
Reagan aggressively,
especially
his--or especially his,
what he refers to
as Reaganomics,
a system of economic reform
that radically cut taxes to
the wealthy and the idea
that they would get a lot
more money and they would
invest more in society,
and then it
would trickle down,
the investments, to the
middle and working-classes,
trickledown economics,
something that Jesse Jackson
thought had ravished,
ravaged the American economy
and the
working-class in particular.
And he sees Reaganomics
as quite morally bankrupt.
And I want to play for you
a clip from the Dem--the,
the, the nomination
speech--the convention
speech, excuse me.
And you have the
actual, you know,
a version of
this speech in the,
in the reader, I know, but
it is also important to hear
people, speakers
like Jesse Jackson,
for the way in which the
great--they carry on the
great oral
tradition of, sort of,
the black minister, the
black vernacular tradition.
And partly, that great black
vernacular tradition allows
someone like Jackson to
access the language of
morality and, in
this case, immorality,
what he sees in the
current state of affairs.
Now you'll see
during--unfortunately,
during a highlight
moment of his speech,
this is on C-SPAN and so
they are obliged to show the
crowd, and they linger for
a very long time over two
people who were then a lot
more culturally relevant in
a celebrity sort of
way than they are now,
Ally Sheedy and
one of the Baldwin,
one of the other
Baldwin brothers.
Actually don't
remember which one it is.
But, but, so just, you know,
kind of visually ignore that
and, and listen to what
Jackson is saying here.
Rev. Jesse Jackson:
Leadership must meet the
moral challenge of its day.
What's the moral
challenge of our day?
We have public
accommodations.
We have the right to vote.
We have open housing.
What's the fundamental
challenge of our day?
It is to end
economic violence.
Plant closings
without notice,
economic violence.
Even the greedy do not
profit long from greed,
economic violence.
Most poor
people are not lazy.
They are not black.
They are not brown.
They are mostly white
and female and young.
But whether white,
black, or brown,
a hungry baby's belly turned
inside out is the same
color.
Color it pain;
color it hurt;
color it agony.
Most poor people
are not on welfare.
Some of them are illiterate
and can't read the want-ad
sections.
And when they can, they
can't find a job that
matches the address.
They work hard every day.
I know.
I live amongst them.
I'm one of them.
I know they work.
I'm a witness.
They catch the early bus.
They work every day.
They raise other
people's children.
They work every day.
They clean the streets.
They drive dangerous cabs.
They work every day.
They change the
beds you slept in,
in these hotels last
night, and can't get a union
contract.
They work every day.
No, no, they are not lazy!
Someone must defend
them because it's right;
they cannot speak
for themselves.
They work in hospitals.
I know they do.
They wipe the bodies of
those who are sick with
fever and pain.
They empty their bedpans.
They clean out
their commodes.
No job is beneath them,
and yet when they get sick,
they cannot lie in the
bed they made up every day.
America, that is not right.
We are a better
nation than that.
So you'll see in
this, this clip here,
that Jackson is
talking about,
is engaging the economic
issues of the day and
linking it to what he sees
as a moral failing of the
leadership of
the, of the moment.
Jackson is speaking
against--in addition to,
I'm sorry, this economic
logic that was a sort of
reverse Robin Hood, this
trickledown economics,
he's also speaking about a
culture of covert racial
politics that has come to
define much of the 1980s.
Now, doing a quick survey,
going backwards now to the
early 1970s, President
Nixon is in office.
But due to culture of
paranoia that's in the White
House, his whole presidency
goes up in flames in
Watergate.
Gerald Ford is
brought into office,
after Nixon's,
former president,
had to be let go.
Nixon was actually pretty
good on affirmative action
issues, but used--in terms
of trying to create job
opportunities for African
Americans--but he used it in
a rather vicious
way, as a wedge issue,
to sort of break apart
blacks and labor unions,
labor unions being, having a
very troubled relationship
to affirmative action,
because it disrupted the,
the, the
traditions of seniority.
So Nixon uses affirmative
action as a tactic.
Ford comes in office and
he's better on civil rights,
but overall a lukewarm
presidency on civil rights
issues.
And he's really, I
mean as it turns out,
a transitional president.
And then this
mystery from Plains,
Georgia, Jimmy Carter,
former governor of Georgia,
sort of comes
out of the blue,
a very moderate
Democrat, who now,
as our politics have gotten
more conservative in this
country, looks like some
kind of crazy liberal often.
But he's a very
moderate Democrat.
And actually, on,
on, on racial issues,
he's actually
pretty progressive,
speaking of a southern
tradition of governors,
certainly.
Carter is able to
speak to black America,
unlike previous
Presidents had been able to.
He wins huge black vote,
ninety percent of the black
vote; five point two million
blacks vote for Carter.
He wins by one point
seven million votes.
Now whenever people talk
about this population,
that population, got
someone elected into office,
I mean, you can cut and
slice the statistics any way
you can, but the belief
was certainly there that the
black vote delivered
Carter into the White House.
And there was an
expectation of return.
So while Jesse Jackson's
organizing economic boycotts
and, and developing into
the star that he would
be--really become, Carter
is wrestling over how to
diversify the executive
branch of the federal
government.
He starts making
numerous appointments,
African Americans.
Fifteen
ambassadors are now black;
thirty federal judges,
fifty--fifty sub-Cabinet
officials, a hundred and ten
members of advisory boards,
twenty-five members of
the White House staff.
These are numbers that
no one had seen before.
And we really are--I mean
there's a statistic that's,
that's worth
keeping in mind.
We aren't out of the woods
when it comes to thinking
about numbers and race
in political office,
by the way.
In 1972, we have the first
time in seventy years that
you have a, a black person
elected to Congress from the
South.
So there's no black
representation from the
South in Congress, from
the turn of the twentieth
century into 1972, right
before Carter takes office.
It would be
another twenty years,
not until 1992, that North
Carolina and Georgia send a
black representative, first
time since Reconstruction.
So when we're talking
about putting White House
appointees in place, it may
sound kind of trivial today,
but you need to understand
that there has been an
erasure of black presence
at the federal level,
especially from
the South--and,
and Carter
brings up an army of,
of southern folks
into the White House.
One of the slams against him
is that he didn't understand
D.C.
In fact, he tried to
play himself against D.C.,
and he brought in all these
southern yokels--this was
the critique--that didn't
understand how to navigate
D.C., but he brought up
these traditions as well.
A tradition of
black erasure,
but Carter changes that.
He was a real progressive
on that re--in that regard.
But still there
is controversy.
Andrew Young, former
civil rights activist
extraordinaire, he's a
United Nations ambassador,
big deal, but meets
with Yasser Arafat without
authorization.
He's forced to resign.
There's this always
lingering connection between
African Americans and the
"Jewish question" in the
Middle East and Palestine.
But what really does Carter
in is not sort of black
advisers doing things
with great independence.
Basically, it's a largely
ineffective presidency.
The economy that had gone
in the tank during the Nixon
and Ford administration
stays in the tank with
Carter.
Students in Iran
capture the U.S.
embassy and start
hostages--keep,
keep hostages,
keeps them for the,
the remainder of the Carter
presidency--presidency.
Carter actually tried to
have this incredible raid,
storm the embassy, and then
it was destroyed by complete
ineptitude in the deserts,
and Carter was exposed for
being just ineffective
across the board.
Seeing an opportunity, tried
to step in and bring back
America's pride.
Oh one thing I
forgot to mention,
part of the economic
challenges here is
incredible oil crises.
The Middle East is rising
up in a coherent way that
hadn't been seen before
and is crippling the United
States over oil.
This is a period of
incredible rationing of oil.
Where, I know in Maryland,
where I was living at the
time with my parents,
depending on your license
plate number, you could
get gasoline on Monday,
Wednesday, and
Friday, or Tuesday,
Thursday, and Saturday.
That was it.
And my parents would go and
get gasoline at the local,
local store, and they'd
be gone for three hours,
because the line
was miles long,
just to get gasoline.
The country was
caught in a vise grip.
And the former
governor from California,
Ronald Reagan, sees this
as a great opportunity to
finally realize his
presidential goals.
He runs on a campaign of
trying to bring pride back
to the United
States, you know,
embolden the
American presence overseas.
He has this idea
about an economic,
a new economic model that
plenty of people are willing
to try, because
nothing else is working.
And Reagan, with his
incredible oratorical gifts,
and they're really quite
stunning--only Clinton and
Obama can come close
to Reagan's gifts,
and they actually modeled
themselves off Reagan's
oratorical styles.
Reagan ultimately
wins in a landslide,
wipes out a
sitting pres--president,
and he's given carte blanche
to set a new agenda for the
country, set a new
agenda in Washington,
D.C.
He runs on a
prob--on a, on a platform,
largely saying that
government is the problem,
something we've all become
quite familiar hearing from
political conservatives,
and now especially the,
the fringe Tea Party, the
political fringe in the Tea
Party, that the federal
government is the problem,
and that if we could just
go back to the day when the
federal government
wasn't so intrusive,
we'd find our way
out of this mess.
Reagan articulates this most
famously when he declares
that he's--officially
declares that he's running
for president.
Now he's running
around, you know,
testing out the talk in
various places quietly in
the country, but
he makes his public
declar--declaration for his
candidacy in Mississippi,
at the state fair.
And he declares at the
state fair in Philadelphia,
Mississippi--I hope that
rings a bell--that he's for
states' rights.
Again, federal
government is the problem;
states' rights
are the solution.
In
Philadelphia, Mississippi.
Now it's important
to belabor the point,
just in case, just to
make sure you don't miss it.
When, when Reagan does this,
it shocks people as much as
it excites people.
Certainly his
political base is thrilled.
"Finally, someone who's
going to get the federal
government off
our damn back."
Civil rights
activists are horrified,
for reasons I hope are
painfully obvious to you at
this point.
I've already laid out over
the course of the last few
weeks this, this
battle, no longer simmering,
between the federal
government's ability to
exert authority versus
the state--individual state
governments.
So much of the civil rights
agenda of the 1960s was
about creating federal
oversight into elections,
for instance, and to access
for public accommodation,
places of public conveyance.
The federal government was
seen by African Americans
and other civil
rights activists--quote,
friends of the movement--the
federal government is seen
to be the most responsible
entity to preserve
citizenship
rights, and Reagan says,
"No, that--the government
is actually the problem.
Let's give power
back to the states."
Now when you are
going to Mississippi,
or any southeastern
state at that time,
the civil rights--the
heights of the civil rights
movement are just
a decade previous.
When you go to these places
and declare you're for
states' rights,
everybody knows,
black as well as white,
what you're talking about.
You're talking about a
return of the organizing,
or the, the centralizing
power of people like Bull
Connor, people
like Orval Faubus.
You're talking about
authorizing the economic
power of Citizens' Councils.
You're talking about
supporting in covert ways
the Ku Klux Klan in the
worst of the situations.
Now I mentioned a few
moments ago that Jesse
Jackson's fighting
against economic policies.
And this is in
his speech in'88,
the economic policies
that Reagan puts into motion
after he wins
the presidency.
And he's also
fighting against an aura,
or an era I should say,
of covert racial politics.
And this is where
Reagan's announcement is so
particularly important.
Reagan never mentions
anything about race when he
declares for the presidency.
But when you talk
about states' rights in
Philadelphia, Mississippi,
the site where Schwerner,
Goodman, and Chaney
were disappeared,
people understand what
you're talking about.
And this is what has
happened to the--and we'll
see, over the course of
the next two lectures,
this is what has happened to
the conversation about race
in America, in what is
allegedly the post-civil
rights moment.
The laws are on the books,
the Voting Rights Act--the
Civil Rights Act,
the Voting Rights Act.
Affirmative action is there.
You have all these
mechanisms in place to
pre--preserve citizenship
that have been race-based
because they've
been race-denied.
It is certainly not
fashionable any longer,
unless you're out on
the political fringe,
to, to race-bait in a way
that you could have before.
You know, Bull
Connor was proven wrong.
You can't be like Bull
Connor and expect to have a
political future.
It's uncomfortable to talk
about race in a way that
someone might,
someone might interpret as,
as negative.
No one wants to be
seen as a po--as,
as racist, certainly no one
who wants to get elected to
office, because if he starts
being seen as a racist,
well, Jesse Jackson's going
to rally the troops and come
after you.
And I'm not
really being fanciful;
I'm being literal.
And so you have a
rise of politicians,
and Reagan is an
absolute expert at it,
that can talk about race
politics with never talking
about race.
And that moment, as you'll
see over--again over the
next two lectures, has never
left and every politician
since has mastered
it just as well.
And we'll pick up on
that on Wednesday.
Thank you.